it's a historic day here in las vegas we
are just hours away from the grand
opening of resorts world it is the first
new property on the strip
in more than a decade our bianca holman
got a look inside and is live now with
what you can expect hi bianca
hey good afternoon alex i can definitely
say
having been inside myself yesterday this
property is impressive it's state of the
art
and it's going to definitely help revive
the north part of the strip you can see
the countdown is up it's 10 hours 56
minutes
and 33 seconds until the grand opening
with three brands in one this property
offers world-class
world class a service there so you know
it's every kind of experience that you
can't imagine that's
the hilton conrad and crawford's appeals
to every kind of tourist
families to the luxury travel luxury
traveler excuse me will enjoy every inch
of this tech savvy space
from cashless gambling world-class
shopping to ordering food from any spot
on the property with a touch of your
phone
this 3000 room oasis is one of a kind
and this morning there was the
clark county commissioner he helped flip
the switch for the new traffic signal at
las vegas boulevard and resorts world
this entrance and exit to the new resort
connects the boulevard
to sammy davis junior drive you see it's
convention centers across the street so
during the conventions we need to have
this
these pathways across the street so it's
essential for this hotel
but the point is it didn't just happen
we were the county's been working
closely with the developer
to make it for today
yeah so this is a prime location and
traffic is definitely going to flow
in and out of the property miley cyrus
set to perform july 4th
iconic artists like celine dion popular
singers like carrie underwood
and luke bryan all have signed deals to
take the stage in the 5 000 seat theater
that's on the property
also resorts world it will open to the
public
they say they're going to let 2 thousand
people in at nine o'clock and then
there's of course a big opening at 11
p.m and of course we're going to be
there there's a major and big party
so again very very exciting time for
everybody especially the north part of
the strip
a new gym here on the las vegas
boulevard alex yeah and especially
coming out of the pandemic too bianca i
know you got to be inside for a few
hours yesterday
is there anything in particular that
stood out to you i'm sure that there was
a lot of great stuff
yeah so alex i would definitely say each
property has its own identity and brand
very intimate feel when you go into the
lobby also while there is no
general overall theme to the resort
there are asian influences and they
definitely
show homage and definitely show respect
to old las vegas matter of fact right in
one of the
hotel lobbies they have a big portrait
of elvis presley and then also one other
thing i will say
that there's a lot of natural light that
comes in on the casino floor
along the street restaurant row where
they have the street eats there there's
a huge
windows that really shine light in i
know sometimes on casino floors it can
feel like a cave but
the resorts world they really make it
feel open and airy a nice
flow to the whole property alex yes and
great reporting out there bianca i will
see you out there tonight thank you so
much all right so when it comes to
technology resorts world
sets a whole new standard bianca's been
showing us some of this too so
all the bar tops have charging ports
look like that you can order
food from touch screens pay and pour
your own beer
just off the casino floor it's super
easy and the real centerpiece
is the 117 000 square foot casino it's
1400 machines
and 130 table games they're all linked
you can download the resort app and
control your wagering and rewards
straight from your smartphone
every chip has a sensor that tracks your
bets and sends that information
right back to you we really brought
the slot and table game ecosystem
together and bundled it
into our resorts world app and our
resorts world loyalty program
and so that's where we think we've got a
real unique differentiator
nobody in the country has what we have
we
pulled everything together the best of
the technologies
to deliver a unique experience for the
guests resorts world also partnered with
grubhub
so guests can order from more than a
dozen restaurants get delivery straight
to your room or even
at the pool it's way too easy there's
also a ton of dining inside
food court spans almost the entire
length of the casino
it's called famous foods has an asian
street vibe with 16 restaurants
and there's also a hidden speakeasy
there are seven
signature restaurants nine casual
eateries and several other bars and
lounges
we sat down with billy richardson he is
the owner of marigold lobster burgers
it's a new american restaurant there
he says it's nice to see a resort
opening at a time like this
we're super excited to be here it's uh
after everything that we've gone through
um it's great that vegas is opening up a
new big building
so you know when we open these buildings
in town it draws a lot of attention and
and that's what we need we need we want
people to come here and enjoy
most of the food options they're right
off the casino floor so you don't have
to go too far to grab a bite and they
look so good
resorts world also has a five acre pool
complex with nine
pools there's also a more
family-friendly pool and a
really cool vip infinity pool with strip
views
one cool note too a lot of the trees
around the pool area they were recovered
from the old stardust before it was
imploded back in 2007
they were transferred to a nursery then
moved back here for resorts world
the day club and nightclub won't open
until next week it is a gorgeous
property we'll have full coverage for
you all day right here on channel 8.